l'été dernier marilou a participé pour
la première fois de sa vie à une course
à pied un exploit qui n'a pas de prix
pour cette adolescente de 14 ans moi
j'ai couru d'un conseil qui le mans
était avec avec move l'infernal à
obstacles en place un tout petit mari
lui mangeait beaucoup ses parents tous
deux aux prises avec des problèmes de
poids observée une frustration lorsqu'il
tentait de réduire ces portions fait au
courant de ce que jamais un surpoids
quand même assez important
c'est je voyais dans les communications
physique et je la voyais aussi andorre
très sévère l'âge de 10-11 a clos sa
comme des rapideaux avait pris comme
kara au liban
[Musique]
au canada presque un enfant sur trois
souffre d'embonpoint ou d'obésité
pour la première fois mondialement mais
vrai aussi ici au canada
l'espérance de vie de nos enfants bien
d'acheter 2 3
si bien que des parents envisage le
recours aux régimes amaigrissants pour
régler le problème de poids de leurs
enfants
les scieries gm enfin le pied ça durait
pas un mois d'un mois maximum
on avait déjà ça y est il s'est pas
vraiment des régimes autistes genre
autres et un menu santé où on avait déjà
essayé rappelle unis en donne moi des
fois ça peut créer des frustrations été
fait c'est moi j'ai toujours été dans
les régimes alimentaires disent qu'à un
moment donné ça marche juste pu noter la
perte de poids et l'homme c'est pratique
c'est le dialogue nous disait qu'on peut
pas faire un régime la fin de stage lomé
de bain c'est maintenant lesquels
olivier deleu jus les matières grasses
le fromage les régimes amaigrissants
sont nombreux et maintenant accessibles
en un clic
la dernière nouveauté turbo de weight
watchers une application pour les 8 à 17
ans une approche qui inquiète des
professionnels de la santé
c'est une catastrophe d'avoir permis la
mise en marché de cette application là
la pédiatre gd saint-pierre consacre sa
carrière à lutter contre l'obésité chez
des enfants
elle est aussi membre de comités
internationaux qui oeuvrent à trouver
des solutions durables pour contrer
cette épidémie on va entretenir le mythe
de la solution facile et mira turbo
classifie des aliments en trois
catégories rouge à éviter jaune à
consommer de façon limitée et verte
aucune restriction il sent que les
aliments soient classifiés selon le
niveau où l'apport en énergie en
calories et non pas selon la valeur
nutritionnelle de l'aliment alors par
exemple au beurre d'arachide se
retrouvent dans les rouges alors que la
teneur en protéines et est élevé donc
c'est pas le mauvais éléments c'est
juste une question d'équilibré
et cette application là ne permet aucune
nuance les utilisateurs de l'application
ont aussi accès à des capsules vidéo ou
des jeunes témoignent de leur succès
qu'ils attribuent à curbans
maintenant la tête des enfants qu'ils
doivent perdre du poids sans avoir une
évaluation par un professionnel qui
valide effectivement ce besoin là est en
soi un danger c'est très préoccupant
parce que un régime hypocalorique ou une
application qui fait la promotion d'un
régime hypocalorique a des effets très
inquiétant au niveau de la croissance
des jeunes aux 6e jeux de la va
reprendre le dos du poids qu'il a perdue
pendant qu'il était sous le régime
nous avons confronté weight watchers à
ces affirmations
ils nous ont répondu que cure beau n'est
pas une diète mais au programme de
gestion poids qui mise sur les
changements d'habitudes de vie tels que
la saine alimentation et l'activité
physique
weight watchers soutient que les
programmes de gestion du poids brazy sur
le comportement ne cause pas de troubles
alimentaires
bien qu'ils aient ferme aussi que cette
application n'est pas destiné au marché
canadien
il nous a été facile de les télécharger
notre carte de crédit a même été débité
de 69 dollars américains pour avoir
accès à leurs services de coaching
distance
je pense qu'une application c'est pas
comme aller chez le docteur fait avoir
un suivi dans une clinique ses parts et
feuillet vraiment ces programmes est
pour toi composeront la proche par des
groupe multidisciplinaire composée de
médecins nutritionnistes kinésiologue
psychoéducateurs ou psychologue donne de
bons résultats
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
l'institut national d'excellence en
santé et services sociaux recommande 25
heures d'intervention personnalisé par
année auprès des familles afin de lutter
contre ce fléau au centre circuit et aux
cliniques 180 on travaille selon cette
approche et c7 est venu que marie d'auch
a choisi il y a maintenant un an après
recommandation de son médecin
il y avait deux tours dans son sac il
faisait que son succès vraiment trop
haut
c'est marrant moi et on
diagnostiquer le prédiabète on a une
augmentation de maladies chroniques
diabète de maladies du coeur cancer dont
tous ont pour dénominateur commun
l'obésité la sur consommation du sucre
surtout la sédentarité la qualité du
sommeil liés à l'usagé intensif des
écrans ne sont que quelques facteurs qui
entraîne l'augmentation du poids c'est
multifactoriel si vous dormez - parce
que vous êtes plus sur votre écran vous
aurez plus de fringale le lendemain si
vous avez des fringales
vous irez nécessairement plus vers des
produits ultra transformer et riches en
gras en sucre en sel
vous serez prêt c'est donc vous ferez
moins de sport qu'à l'habitude au québec
on compte cinq cent mille jeunes en
surpoids la moitié vont développer une
forme d'obésité
alors on parle de maladies des yeux dans
cette clinique les épidémies ou à vélo
des l'obésité infantile marco illy yonne
maladie déclarée depuis 2013
à ce jour le canada nul québec n'a
accepté de déclarer la maladie
prendre pour cent des enfants mais un
adulte sur deux souffre d'embonpoint et
d'obésité donc du jour au lendemain on
déclare la moitié de la population du
québec ou du canada comme étant malade
imaginez les frais relatifs à tous à
l'obésité coûtent cher au québec déjà en
2011 on évaluait l'impact économique de
l'obésité uniquement chez les adultes à
près de trois milliards de dollars